Beep beep.
Beep beep beep beep.
Welcome back to Half-Life.
Except... two!
The second one!
Yippee!
Beep beep.
Oh my gosh, the sounds of the radios are triggering me a little bit.
I'm like, who's there?
Who's around the corner?
What?
Beep beep.
Yeah, I'm on dark mode today because it's a little... I don't know.
I was like, this is my gear.
This is my gear!
You love the radio?
It doesn't freak you out?
It doesn't make you be like...
Ugh!
Somebody's here!
No, I'm with the science team.
Peek Phantom playing Peek Fiction.
This is fiction?
I'm Jay.
Thank you so much for the fun.
I've gifted.
Thank you!
Yesterday's stream was the perfect birthday present!
Thank you for making me laugh so hard and for mowing the pond.
Hey.
I have a special gift.
Happy birthday!
Glad I could make you laugh.
Yeah.
One of my favorite games of all time.
Really?
Look at that guy walking around.
What is that mask on that he's got?
Alright.
Where are we?
Dark Minky, my beloved.
It's been a minute, right?
Dark Minky of the Half-Life, what is your wisdom?
Um...
Don't shoot!
I'm with the science team!
Is that a crowbar in your pants?
Or are you happy to see me?
It's in my hands.
Yesterday was one of the greatest bits of...
I've ever seen for a regular non-event stream.
Here's 25 credits worth...
Oh, sorry.
No.
Here's 100 credits worth of quarters.
Um...
Thank you!
I just... I was just being goofy.
If you guys don't know, you can watch the...
my...
Jurassic Park Arcade!
Stream Key!
Thank you so much for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Did you still sell lemonade?
I had just had the one cup left.
I... you know...
I made enough for one.
This most special...
crafted with care...
cup of lemonade...
you'd ever, ever, ever come across!
Half-Life 2, where was full life one?
Yeah!
Would this be...
the other...
part...
other...
half...
wait...
ha...
Now this...
pla...
this...
plus...
Half-Life 1...
Half-Life 2...
equals...
full life...
1...
We're not choosing...
...
with that!
Jesus 3...
as for now.
...
Yes!
Thank you guys so much!
Free-æ› foot licker, thank you for the...
This is the second other gift that I saw before.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you guys for all the...
Who knows, and my boy ships, thank you.
Miss Mel-chan, thank you for the pocket today, thank you.
Yeah, I'm excited to play this, so...
I'm excited.
It's an early stream for me, quite early.
So maybe some of you guys are at work.
And if you are, I'm here to whisper sweet nothings into your ears so you can get through the work day.
But it's also Friday!
Yippee!
It's Friday, and if you're not at work, and you're just chilling, hanging out with me, maybe you got off work already, because it's later, eww...
Dan, otu!
Otu, otu!
And...
Yeah!
I just decided, I was like, I want to try doing more midday streams, and I...
For me, at least.
And so, a little bit...
At least have some...
A few more EU-friendly streams in my...
In my lineup!
Hot dog, indeed!
Finally managed to catch you live, so it's good to see you!
Thank you, Sargei!
Thank you, thank you.
Ear whispers, let's go!
I'm summoning a demon?
Sending my Han's money to Minto instead.
Fuzzy, I hate to break it to you, but what...
Five bucks in a gacha game is like pennies.
How much is a ten-pole in Uma?
Hi, Minto!
Hi!
Twenty...
Twenty?
Fourteen on sale.
Twenty bucks.
Twenty...
Twenty-five.
Yes!
I'm at work right now.
And have you projected on the break room TV?
I will bring culture to my workplace.
I will be work-friendly then!
I will attempt.
There will be an attempt.
Half-Life plus Half-Life 2 equals Half-Life Alex.
So she's three years old!
Three years old!
Unemployed gang, rise up!
Don't send me a super chat then!
Save your money!
EU time slot for a game set in mythical land known as Central Europe.
Is this?
Are we actually?
Well, I guess we should get started then, huh?
I guess we should get started.
I'm confused though.
I'm obviously...
I'm guessing I just click Half-Life 2.
And that...
It'll play Half-Life 2 Episode 1 and 2.
Nope.
Yes?
Okay.
The game is about Europe, then it's perfect for EU time, right?
So, last time...
Half-Life 1 ended.
Um...
The scary...
The scary skibbity man came to us and he said, I like what you're doing, kid.
I wanna hire you.
And we went to the...
What was it called?
Um...
The ZEN!
Oh, the dimension between realms.
Yeah, we went there, and we shot many monsters, and we killed a big baby.
Yeah, we did that.
And, yeah, then Mr. Skibbity came to us and he said, I like your riz.
I like your riz.
I want to hire you.
And, and we could either say, no way, Jose, and be teleported to a place where you just die.
Or you could, um, you could, uh, say yes and then end the game.
So that's what we did.
Greetings from Otaku-thon.
Missing you.
Any messages you want to pass to Matara and Laimu?
Oh, uh, Batara, say, stinky, stinky mama.
And Laimu, say, I love Laimu.
Oh, speaking of Laimu, I got to talk about her a lot.
Because, um, uh, uh, at the Metal Gear thing, I also got to meet Vinnie Vinesauce.
He was there.
And, uh, I got to be like, I love Laimu.
I feel like any time I talked to her, I was like, so Laimu?
Laimu?
I love her.
So, yeah, I really like Laimu.
Yeah, I got to meet that guy.
Um, it was very nice.
Okay.
Okay, Half-Life 2.
I also got to tell him that I like his...
His, like, glitch streams.
His glitch playthroughs of...
Metal Gear.
No.
Okay.
Achievements.
New game.
Are these spoilers?
Enable commentary.
What?
Wait, will the devs talk to me?
That's kind of crazy.
Diaperchief.
Oh my gosh, I forgot to tell him that.
It's great.
Enable yap mode.
Maybe, maybe if I ever play...
But this is my first time playing, so I don't want yap mode.
They could spoil.
And then I'll be like, oh no.
Oh, no.
Rise and shine, Mr. Freeman.
Rise and shine.
Oh, wow.
Not that I wish to imply you have been sleeping on the job.
I think you need some more sleep.
No one is more deserving of a rest.
And all the effort in the world would have gone to waste.
Until...
Well...
Let's just say your hour has come again.
Yes.
The right man in the wrong place...
Dramatic pause.
Can make all the difference in the world.
Difference.
So wake up, Mr. Freeman.
Wake up and smell the ashes.
The ashes?
Hello, sir.
Good morning.
I didn't see you get on.
I've been here the whole time.
This is my third transfer this year.
Wow, it already looks so good.
Oh, like it already...
Hello.
No matter how many times I've been relocated...
I'm getting used to it.
End of the line.
Oh, you're pushing me out the door.
Okay, you really want me to get to work up.
It looks so good.
You have chosen...
Or been chosen...
To relocate to one of our finest remaining urban centers.
I feel like I'm at the Hunger Games.
So much in City 17 that I elected to establish my administration here in the Citadel so thoughtfully provided by our benefactors.
I've been proud to call City 17 my home.
And so, whether you are here to stay or passing through on your way to parts unknown, Welcome to City 17.
Chill.
It's safer here.
Yeah, it's safer here.
What is that?
What the?
I like the credits.
Very cinematic.
It was already cinematic in the first game.
And it's now even so much more cinematic.
Are you gonna...
Are you gonna be nice to that guy?
He's just...
He's just sweeping.
You're sweeping everything into the...
Into the corner.
Is that our booty shot, man?
Booty shot.
You have chosen...
Or been chosen...
To relocate to one of our finest remaining urban centers.
I'm just looking around.
I'm taking it all in.
Booty shot.
It is!
Zerker, thank you so much for the tech gift.
Thank you!
I don't know.
Where are the...
I was just thinking.
Thank you.
I was thinking about the subtitles.
Audio, maybe?
Oh, captions.
Here we go.
Closed captions, I guess.
I've been proud to call City 17 my home.
And so, whether you are here to stay or...
Passing through on your way to...
Parts Unknown.
Hello?
Welcome.
To City 17.
Did that not work?
I thought that would do everything.
Dialogue only.
Looking forward to this Half-Life 2 rocks.
Thank you!
I vaguely recall you said you wanted to lick up speedruns...
After you finished Half-Life 1.
Did you?
I didn't actually!
Maybe I will, because I have time today.
Ah, here we go.
Gotth Ghostbade Mint whispering sweet nothing into my ears.
Blush blush.
Also petition to release the sexy button.
Blush is harder.
No!
I actually looked it up.
First warning.
Live away.
But this stuff...
It's all I have left.
Good luck.
Move it.
All right, I'm moving.
Jeez.
No, let it take a stop.
Hey, you don't...
I...
I'm big news here.
Oh my gosh!
Ouch!
Okay.
Welcome to City 17.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
You have chosen, or been chosen, to relocate to one of our finest remaining urban centers.
I thought so much of City 17 that I elected to establish my administration here.
Can I knock over everything?
In the citadel so thoughtfully provided by our benefactors.
I got your stuff, bro.
Oh.
I've got to call City 17 my home.
I got it for you.
Are you the only ones on that train?
And so, whether you are here to stay or passing...
What's the girl from the, from my thumbnail?
Welcome to City 17.
Hello.
It's safer here.
Overwatch stopped our train in the woods and took my husband for questioning.
Eat a grab.
They said he'd be on the next train.
I'm not sure when that was.
They're, they're being nice though, letting me wait for him.
Wait, so eat a grab?
Oh!
Wait, what was this?
A boot.
Is there a way I can throw?
You have chosen, or been chosen, to relocate to one of our finest remaining urban centers.
Oops, sorry.
I thought so much of City 17 that I elected to establish my administration here.
Even the citadel so farfully provided by our...
Oh no.
Oh!
I've been proud to call City 17 my home.
She shoots!
And so, whether you are here to stay or passing the two on your way to...
She scores!
Cool!
Oh, yes, yes, yes!
Yes!
The vending machines still work!
Oh.
Well, they did.
No more!
I just...
I just broke a bottle over her head.
Change.
Someone's talking.
Oh my god, this guy is just never ending talking.
I get it.
I'm in the city.
I'm really trying to up that affection level.
Yeah.
Hat dog indeed.
What can I say?
I'm, uh, I'm, uh, I'm, uh, you know, I like you.
I tease you a little by throwing things at your head.
Oh my god, everybody's talking.
The city is based on multiple different settings in Eastern and Central Europe.
Viktor Antonov, the art director, grew up in Sofia.
I've used it for the layout, but a bunch of the architectures...
Literally, literally, just various countries as government buildings.
Oh, no way!
I am scared to go in there, are you?
That guy, he's like, meh.
Hehehehehe.
Okay.
I'll go.
Where are you taking me?
On me?
Where?
Where are you taking me?
Okay.
Why are you guys just standing around?
Do you enjoy watching me behind bars?
Welcome.
Welcome to City 17.
You have chosen or been chosen to relocate to one of our finest lands.
Remaining urban centers.
I thought...
Ah!
What did I do?
What did I...
Oh my god, is it the back?
Okay.
I'm a thief!
And so, whether you are here to...
This must be a mistake.
I got a standard relocation coupon just like everybody else.
I'm being nosy.
Hello?
Oh.
Now I'm good.
You!
I've been...
I haven't moved.
I'm gonna need me some privacy for this.
About that beer I owed ya.
It's me, Gordon.
Barney from Black Mesa.
Barney!
Sorry for the scare.
I had to put on a show for the cameras.
Oh my god.
Barney!
They'll get suspicious.
I'm way behind on my beating quota.
Yes, Barney.
What is it?
I'm in the middle of a critical test.
Everybody's here!
Sorry doc, but...
Look who's here.
It's me!
Scott!
Gordon Freeman!
I didn't expect more warning.
Yeah, you and me both, Doc.
He was about to board the Express to Nova Prospect.
Well, Barney, what do you intend?
I'm thinking, I'm thinking!
Alex is around here somewhere.
She would have a better idea of getting here.
Well, as long as he stays away from checkpoints, we should be okay.
Listen, I gotta go, Doc.
We're taking enough chances as it is.
Very well.
And, uh...
Gordon?
Good to see you.
Okay, Gordon.
Yep.
You're gonna have to make your own way to Dr. Kleiner's lab.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, man!
That's what I was afraid of!
Get in here, Gordon!
Before you blow my cover!
Okay!
I'm in!
Pile up some stuff to get through that window, and keep going until you're in the plaza!
I'll meet up with you later!
I love you, Barney!
Okay, we're gonna pile up stuff.
Alright.
I can just use the stairs.
I can just use...
Okay.
The ladder.
That's what I meant to say.
Alright.
There we go.
Awesome.
Awesome!
Okay, here I go.
Can I make this fall?
Or...
I sure hope I can.
Oh!
Thank you for the breath!
Hello!
Hi, everybody!
Thank you, Skye.
Hello, hello.
Oh, I just started Half-Life 2.
So...
I sure hope nobody heard that.
I'm gonna take this for self-defense.
Thank you for the gift, you guys.
Thank you!
Sorry.
I feel like this game is so hard to reach out while I go through it.
Oh.
Push the door.
It is open.
Oh, it opens the other way.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Let's
go get my cinder block.
Mimi!
Hi.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, it's heavy.
Um...
At least he doesn't notice.
Pick up that can.
Oh, this?
Immotality.
Is...
In our own reach.
Now, this...
Simplified.
Has far-reaching implications.
Ah!
Wait!
No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to...
Everyone does that though, right?
I got the...
I got an achievement.
Everybody does that.
Probably.
Oh.
He took that like a champ.
This guy just is always yappin'.
Pick up that can.
Okay.
Wait, where is the can?
Oh, man.
Oh!
Did he do that?
I'll teach you to recycle.
It's a rickshot!
Am I the coolest of all time?
I'm the coat!
Hello.
Oh, gosh.
Don't you know who I am?
I'm the hero!
Me and my boyfriend are watching the stream together today since he loves Half-Life and I love Minto!
Hoping to convert him and make two wisps out of one!
Ooh la la!
Thanks, Zombie!
Have fun!
Hello?
What?
We should thank our benefactors for giving us respite from this overpowering force.
They have thrown a switch and exorcised our demons in a single stroke.
They have erased the horny?
We never could have summoned to overcome this compulsion.
What?
They have given us pulse.
They have turned our eyes toward the sky.
Oh!
Wait, what the heck is this thing?
What are you- Look at that posture.
Shikure Ui pose.
Hello?
The line starts at the end.
Oh, okay, sorry.
Line starts at the end.
Can I get my one phone call?
Ho!
Oops.
I think it's broken.
Actually.
Wolf?
Can I talk?
Oh!
Okay.
All right.
None of them want to talk to me.
They don't like me.
And I defy physics.
What's happening?
Wait a second.
Isn't this the door that's like right here?
On the other side?
Oh!
Whoa!
We're outside!
Okay, now where do I need to go?
I'm in Europe!
Look up.
I did.
Whoa!
Oh, I didn't see that.
Holy cow.
Oh!
Hi!
Oh.
Yeah.
Show them how much of a freak you are.
When do I get to be able to run?
Oh my gosh.
Stop following me, freak!
What's going on in there?
Okay.
Sorry.
Soon?
Okay.
Not yet.
Oh!
Hello.
Okay.
I'd like to help you, but it's not a question.
Ow!
Stop flashing my eyes, please!
Okay, I'm guessing we get around by going this way, but I want to explore a little bit more beforehand.
Hello!
Okay.
Is that a turret there?
Interesting.
Interesting, interesting.
Tis himself.
Thank you so much for five gifts.
Thank you.
The paparazzi!
I'm your biggest friend, I'll follow you until you love me.
Oh!
What is that?
Paparazzi!
Can we get over here?
Here.
This one has a little bit of...
...stuff around.
The barbed wire, you know.
What is this?
Oh!
Ah!
Okay!
I'm sorry!
Everything's taking my pictures!
Stop!
Please!
I need access to get in there.
Okay.
Golly!
Okay, so there's nothing else really around here.
It's irrelevant.
Oh!
Wow!
They're like...
You ask for the evidence, we will give it to you.
We will provide.
Does Photoshop not exist in this...
...in this future?
Alright.
No, no.
No, please.
No photos.
Wait, there's a...
There's...
...
I made it?
Wait, I can be here.
Okay, this is fine.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Oh my gosh!
Witnessing a...
...
Something.
Is this roleplay?
Okay.
They don't need a...
They don't need a third.
It's fine.
Hello?
This is how it always starts.
First the building, then the whole block.
They have no reason to come to our place.
Don't worry, they'll find one.
What's going on?
Tell me.
What's happening?
Not that you just looked at me with shifty eyes.
There's even a playground here!
Oh, come on.
Eh...
Oop!
One day?
One...
Yeah!
We're missing a piece though.
Oh!
A baby!
I'm a mother.
Let me in.
Oh!
Yes?
But what's going on in there?
Be free my baby!
Go live your life!
Okay.
Please don't let me in.
Can I play on this?
Woo!
I love the physics.
Oh my gosh.
Physics!
I'm getting dizzy.
Perfect parenting.
Yeah.
You could say...
Can I hit this thing?
Well...
If I...
If I didn't have actual noodle arms, maybe.
Don't think that's how babies work.
It's like...
Finding a stray kitten.
I do not have a flashlight.
Someone's using the potty.
What's upstairs?
Hello?
Oh!
What's going on?
Hey, hold on.
What's...
What's going on?
Hi!
What's happening?
He's one of us.
Yeah?
I told you they'd be coming for us next.
What's going on?
Just at this point.
I hope you're wrong.
Oh!
It's a...
No!
What are those...
What are those cars called?
A Cybertruck!
Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Sorry.
You scared me.
I can't take it anymore.
What are we going to do?
Does anyone have doors?
Or...
Can I turn this guy off?
When is it all going to end?
Please!
Oh my god!
He doesn't shut up!
Please!
Shut up!
Can't see anything in here.
Okay.
Sorry.
Uh...
I don't...
Attention, resident.
What...
Why am I getting...
Why?
Ah!
Ouch!
Oh, I...
Oh, please!
I'm trying to leave!
Ouch!
Ow!
Wait!
I'm trying to get out of here!
Ow!
Ouch!
I'm leaving!
I can't see anything.
Hey, you!
In here!
Okay, thank you.
The roof?
There's no time to lose!
Ah!
Was it me?
What did I do?
Where's the roof?
Failure of the robbery will result in...
Oh!
Oh my god!
I don't know anything that's happening!
Get in here, quick!
I'm in here!
Moving!
Oh my god!
Give me a gun!
Come inside!
Who's hurt?
I didn't get to...
I didn't get to explore!
Oh my god!
They're shooting me!
Look at me!
Ah!
Ow!
Where do I go?
Oh, well, um...
Guys, I, um... I couldn't... I didn't know where to go.
There were planks?
Oh, I totally missed it.
Um, one moment.
Where are they?
Ouch!
Where?
Behind...
The ears!
Are they down here?
Ouch!
Oh, no!
Follow the wall.
The right side.
I'm really stupid, you guys.
Why?
Okay, follow the wall.
She's black!
Clearly I am!
Ah!
They're not helping!
Follow the wall!
Here?
Where am I supposed to go?
You guys!
They're the worst instructors ever.
I'm getting shot at!
I'm just trying to figure...
Oh, my gosh.
I see it.
The tiniest two little planks I've ever seen in my entire afterlife.
The birds!
Oh, the gosh.
Don't shoot the birds.
They're innocent!
The birds are innocent.
Would this have happened regardless?
Oh, yeah!
Escape the apartment block raid.
Oh, they're just attacking everybody?
Ugh!
I can't take it anymore!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my...
Script and ambush!
Oh!
Dr. Freeman, I presume.
That's me.
You can call me Gordon.
The combine can be slow to wake, but once they're up, you don't want to get in their way.
Okay.
They let you wear jeans?
Dr. Kleiner said you'd be coming this way.
I don't think it occurred to him that you might not have a map.
Oh, yeah!
And I'm...
I have an unhelpful chat, too!
I'm Alex Vance.
My father worked with you back in Black Mesa.
I'm sure you don't remember me.
You're so up on the feed!
That's so funny!
You're a few words, aren't you?
You're the blind one!
Remember him from Black Mesa?
Your old administrator.
Don't get my dad started on Dr. Breen.
I keep thinking of Neil Breen.
I can't help it.
Secrets!
Oh, yeah, she moonwalking.
She can't stop staring at me.
A red-letter day?
Why?
What's today?
All the sound effects are so great!
She's too cool.
Does that work?
Here.
Let me buy you a drink.
Are you just gonna punch it?
Wait, she's actually using money!
Oh!
What the?
Oh, and by the way...
Nice to finally meet you.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Find all Lambda caches in Half-Life 2.
Wait, what?
Nice to meet you.
I'm here!
What was that?
I'll get her.
I have physics.
That's me!
It really is you, isn't it?
Yeah.
I found him wandering around outside.
Bit of a troublemaker, isn't he?
We owe a great deal to Dr. Freeman, even if trouble does tend to follow in his wake.
I mean, it's not my fault.
I must say, Gordon, you come at a very opportune time.
I didn't see the planks either.
The final piece for our resurrected teleport.
I can't take any credit for the break here, Doctor.
Like, I thought it was gonna be me falling onto like a...
What's it called?
Let's just see if this thing works, okay?
A box that would break my fall, you know?
Man, Gordon, you stirred up the hive.
Oh, the bunny!
Barney!
We can't keep him here long, Doc.
It'll jeopardize everything we've worked for.
Don't worry.
He's coming with me.
Push me?
That's right, Barney.
This is a red-letter day.
We'll inaugurate the new teleport with a double transmission.
You mean it's working?
For real this time?
Because I still have nightmares about that cat.
No, no.
There's nothing to be nervous about.
We've made major strides since then.
Major strides.
What cat?
Cat?
Since he's not taking the streets, you might as well get him out of his civvies.
What?
Oh, dear.
Where's your cat?
I almost forgot.
Barney, I'll give you the honor.
I've gotta get back on my ship.
But okay.
Are you gonna...
Are you gonna dress me?
Are you gonna Barbie doll me?
Oh!
Here we go.
Ah!
Damn it!
Get it off me!
Oh!
De-beaked?
The worst she might do is attempt to couple with your head, fruitlessly.
Get that thing away from me!
Yeah, my pet.
Hop up!
Literal blind man.
No, not up there!
No!
Careful Lamar!
Oh my god.
Those are quite fragile!
The head crab sounds.
Oh, fine.
It'll be another week before I can coax her out of there.
Nah!
Longer if we're lucky.
You have such a nice, smooth head though.
You have to rip the CRT.
Well, Gordon.
Go ahead.
Slip into your suit now.
Why did they side-eye me so hard?
If Dr. Kleiner says you should wear that thing, you should wear it.
Okay.
This bombastic side-eye.
Barney doesn't though.
Right, Barney?
Barney actually...
Come on, Gordon.
We don't have time to fool around.
Get your suit on.
Okay, goodness.
Hold on.
Everybody was congratulating somebody and I wanna see what's happening.
I wanna see what's up.
Oh wait, did I miss it?
No, please say no.
No.
Wait.
Did I miss it?
What happened?
I wanna congratulate too.
I wanna be part of the fun.
He got to college!
Yippee!
Electrician college.
Wow!
You know, you have...
You have a great career.
Congratulations, Bron!
The NPC's progressed the plot, VTuber.
I know, I'm like...
Oh!
Oh, the valve sound.
It's kinda freaky actually, hearing it like in-game.
Whoa!
Oh!
Hey!
Well, Gordon, I see your HEV suit still fits you like a glove.
At least, the glove parts do.
What am I...
Did I grow taller?
I need a few modifications, but I'll just acquaint you with the essentials.
I could run now?
Oh, yes I can!
The Mark V hazardous environment suit has been redesigned for comfort and utility.
Oh dear.
Doc, we don't have time for this.
Oh.
At least get that suit you stopped, Gordon.
Good idea.
There's a charger on the wall.
Huh?
This one?
I've modified your suit to draw power from combine energy outlets, which are plentiful wherever they patrol.
Okay.
I did, I held down.
Oh, keep going?
Nope, there's mo- There's no more.
Meanwhile, let's get this show on the road.
Okay.
What's go- Oh, you got some blueprints here?
What's going on?
Aw.
Oh.
It's not just- I thought- Aw, I thought you were just hap- Who's the scratched out one?
Hold on, I want to teleport the plant real quick.
It's Breen?
Aw.
Icky, man.
Wait.
Hold on.
Okay, hold on.
I'll get it.
One second!
Does it have to be perfectly in there?
Yeah, the yapper.
Oh!
How cute!
Cute!
It still worked, you guys.
It still worked.
I'm touching everything.
Oh!
What's this?
It keeps moving around.
Hold on!
I'm reading!
Hazardous environment suit.
Okay.
What are we doing?
Sorry, I really like to look at everything, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
Haha.
See the zoom?
Why don't you position yourself near the panel over there and wait for my work.
Isaac, are you there?
Yes, yes, Eli.
Bit of a hold up.
Do I need to go in there?
You'll never guess who found his way into our lab this morning.
That's not who I think it is, is it?
Indeed it is.
And it's our intention to send him packing straight away in the company of your lovely daughter.
Are you ready for us, dad?
We're all set on this end.
Then let's do it.
Cool!
See ya!
Barney, don't you like me anymore?
Why'd you just take a step back?
Huh?
Hey, uh, yeah, about that cat.
The cat!
Two...
One...
No...
Thin-sticks.
What now?
Uh...
Doctor...
The plug.
Uh, dear me.
You're right.
Oh.
Gordon, would you mind...
Plugging us in?
Be a dear and plug you in?
I can- I see!
I'm not that blind.
Oh my god.
You gonna let Gordon throw the switch?
Gordon, go right ahead.
Where's the switch now?
This?
Very good.
Final sequence.
Commencing...
Now, I can't look.
They knew.
Okay.
Are you feeling funny?
Oh no!
Ho ho!
Well, did it work?
See for yourself.
He died!
Oh my god!
My relief is almost palpable.
Fantastic work, is it?
Well, I can't take all the credit.
She did.
Dr. Freeman proved an able assistant.
I plugged in.
I didn't.
I...
Right you are.
Speak to you again in a few moments.
I can't- You can't take all the credit.
I just got you.
I can see your MIT education really pays for itself.
What?
Are they making fun of me?
Gee, thanks.
Gordon, as soon as you're in position, we'll send you to Eli's.
Okay.
Not a moment too soon.
Mom, stop teasing me.
Oh my god, it kind of looks like...
In three, two, one.
Something from Portal, no?
Barney, if you'd be so kind.
Good luck out there, Gordon.
Yes indeed.
Barney!
Best of luck in your future endeavors.
Final sequence.
Uh oh.
The hell?
What is it?
Uh oh.
It's your anchor-freaking headhopper.
Oh no.
Uh oh.
No.
No!
It's Lamar with him.
Get about that thing.
I'm here!
Oh my gosh.
Booty shot!
Okay!
What's the meaning of this?
Who are you?
How did you get in here?
Uh.
This is crazy!
This is so awesome!
I feel like I'm on like some universal ride, you know?
Don't worry, Gordon.
There he is!
Oh, we're losing him again!
Booty shot!
All but certain, it was...
Gordon Freeman.
Then,
where is he?
I'm behind you!
Shut it down!
Gordon!
You must get out of here!
Run!
Get down out of sight!
I'll come find you!
What do you mean, get down out of sight?
Oh my gosh.
I'm sprinting?
Uh, this way?
Come find me!
Please!
What the hell?
Oh!
We're good!
We made it!
I think!
Is there something to climb?
Did I miss something on the ground?
Or these?
Hey, Gordon!
Oh!
Yes?
Hi!
The Citadel's on full alert.
I've never seen it lit up like that.
Get out of City 17 as fast as you can, Gordon.
Take the old canals, right?
They'll get you to Eli's lab.
It's a dangerous route, but there's a whole network of refugees, and they'll help you if they can.
I'd come with you, but I gotta look after Dr. Kleiner.
Oh, and before I forget, I think you dropped this back in Black Mesa.
Stop!
Good luck out there, buddy.
You're gonna need it.
Thank you, Barney!
Okay, so we go through...
We're going through the sewers?
I forgot to ask, does this game have like, autosave?
Okay, it does, but I should probably just like, save when I can do.
The canals.
Uh...
I do.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
I hate these things so much.
Uh...
I'm just gonna...
Where?
I'm just running for it.
Oh, and I can't go that way.
Uh...
And...
Where to go.
No, no.
Please, don't take a picture of me.
I really hate you.
Uh...
No, please.
Please, no photos.
They're so obsessed with me.
Up there!
I think I messed up.
Hold on.
Maybe I can go underneath the train.
Ah!
I messed up everybody.
Is there a train that's open?
Ah!
We're good.
Everything's fine.
Ah!
Everything's not fine!
Okay, everything's fine.
The music is very good, huh?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I'm running, I'm running.
And, um...
Maybe this way.
Uh...
Trying to find a way...
In?
Perhaps this direction?
I wish I had a gun.
I'd take those guys down.
Easy peasy!
No?
Oh my god.
I gotta jump?
Okay.
Oh, from...
Uh...
Where?
Oh my god.
Please.
Please, sir.
I'm just trying to find a way around.
Or...
How did I...
How did I get on the top of the thing anyway?
I don't remember.
Is it here?
Yeah, here we go.
Okay.
I see.
From inside the car, yeah.
Wait!
Whew!
We made it!
We're fine!
We're
fine!
The Root Canal.
I tricked people into paying me to do...
For doing work again.
Oh!
That's exciting.
E the whole...
Oh, nice.
My health is not so bad though.
Shocking.
Actually.
I got you.
You better run.
There's nothing else you can do here.
They were already looking for me!
Oh, I have their gun.
My bad.
Wait.
If I do this, they'll explode and they'll never know.
What about that guy?
Is he okay?
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna go heal.
Okay.
They don't explode anymore!
Depressing.
I like how she's like, they'll be looking for you now.
Honey, they already were.
Come here.
Come here, you.
Yeah!
The sound of them dying is kind of spooky.
Not gonna lie.
Look, someone said...
F6 is...
Is...
Quick save, is that true?
Yeah, they like actually flatline.
It's kind of spooky.
F5.
F6.
Ah!
It is F6.
It's F6, everybody.
At least for me.
I don't like how I only have so much stamina.
That's new, right?
I had...
I'm limited before, no?
Anything in here?
It is new.
Yeah.
Makes me quite sad.
Ooh!
Will this hit me?
I should have tested it.
Can I jump on it?
Can I hitch a ride?
Oh.
Oh, well.
Okay.
Try on top?
How do I even get on?
Oh, wait!
On top.
What?
Uh...
This is actually...
Maybe safer.
Oh,
why do I have to have sprint?
Oh, and I can't go through here.
Okay.
How'd I fail that jump?
I didn't fail.
I literally landed on it.
What are you talking about?
Okay, hold on.
I'll sit right here.
No.
Right here.
No unlimited run.
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
This bar does not actually...
It's not a functional bar.
Oh my god.
I can snipe.
No, I can't.
You can't.
You can't shoot and zoom at the same time.
The red barrels.
A little delayed.
But they...
What the hell?
Don't call for more people, you bastard!
Oh my god.
That's evil.
Uh...
I can hide, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Quit running.
I got his ass.
Okay, now I have to, like, remember what the...
Or, like, know what the new things look like, you know?
I'm afraid someone's gonna shoot that and blow me up!
Is this a game?
Is this a game where you want to always be quicksaving, too?
Kind of like the previous game?
I think I have to blow it up.
Jeez!
Oh, wait!
Not really?
Okay.
Good to know.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, where are you?
I killed somebody.
I'm a murdering machine!
Oh!
I didn't even notice.
Oh, yeah, we...
Oh, there we go.
If it looks like a parkour scene, embrace the interaction here.
Oh, my gosh!
I can't even talk to my chat!
You guys are so rude!
Dude!
I'm guessing they just spawn unlimited...
And that I...
Um...
Parkour.
And that I...
Wait, where do I parkour to?
Where...
Ah, I see!
This is a wall.
Okay, okay.
Huh!
Whip!
Ah!
Whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop-whoop.
Where'd he go?
Oh, my goodness.
I think the other guy is still.
Woo!
I'm gonna run out of bullets because of you guys!
Please!
Oh, my God.
Oh, I see it.
Nice, fancy.
What?
Thank you!
Always be on your guard in this game.
Come here.
Where's your head?
Right...
There.
I'm just gonna run.
And I'm gonna...
Where's how to get down?
Gosh!
Hole?
Oh, yeah.
Whip!
Oh, no!
Not on me!
Oh, uh...
The train again.
Wait, what's this?
Meow.
The goal?
Oh, my Jesus!
Hole things considered?
We're okay.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Why did you...
The anger alert?
I feel like I'm in doom all of a sudden.
I don't know.
Not quite sure...
Not quite sure which way I'm supposed to go...
I guess up these stairs.
That are very obviously here to go up.
Maybe look around, stupid.
Yep!
Wait, where's the...
Oh, here, there we go.
Oh, my gosh.
Please, my aim.
My aim.
Okay.
I guess?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
My ammo.
You're like right in front of me.
How am I missing?
More things.
Oh, this game is like... there's stuff everywhere.
I mean, I know I'm like early right now.
But, like early level, you know.
Uh-oh.
Am I supposed to go down?
Is there anything down there?
I guess so.
We're going, baby.
We're really going.
We're flying.
Also, did someone say Dusko?
Hi, Dusko!
Hello.
Space.
Again.
I'm swimming up whether I want to or not.
All right.
All right, baby.
Get me in.
I'm too fat.
Too fat.
Oh.
God.
Hi.
Good thing you found us.
You're not the first to come through here.
This is the free man.
The Combine's reckoning has come.
Look.
Booty shot.
Main station's right around the corner.
They'll get you started on the right foot.
Meanwhile, let my Vortigaunt friend here give you a jolt to get you going.
Will you?
Wait.
This is so crazy.
You really can't afford to get noticed.
Civil protection catched you down here.
It's bad news for the whole railroad.
We deserve the same victory.
Resist.
Okay.
See ya.
Thank you.
Booty shot.
It would've healed if it wasn't full.
I guess it doesn't do my suit.
Which is understandable, I suppose.
But still sad.
Oh.
You killed the baby brain in the first game and freed them.
Oh, they viewed me as a he...
Ouch!
Oh, I see.
I freed them.
Booty shot.
No way!
That's crazy!
If I take long enough, will he...
Will he come back down?
The ropes.
Oh!
Yes, indeedy.
Oh, wow!
Wow!
Wait, that's awesome.
That's so cool.
Oh, yeah.
You guys were just telling me to distract it.
With the skull.
I was way ahead of you.
Ew, what am I walking through?
No!
I could've saved them.
I was too busy getting...
What?
Oh my god.
I'm just shooting.
Holy...
Holy hell!
Absolute ambush!
I did not save them.
Is this what you were talking about in here?
Okay, I know there's those guys over here.
Holy hell.
They're crazy.
I'm not even hitting you at all.
There's another tunnel.
Hold on.
I got so distracted with the people yelling, I didn't even look around.
Another tunnel.
I think maybe I go through the car.
The slop sound is disgusting.
Jesus.
Oh my gosh, I can't hit him at all.
I can't hit him at all.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
If I die, I die.
It's fine.
Oh.
Oh god, don't go through the car!
Don't go through the car.
The crowbar, let's try it.
No?
It's okay.
We li- we- well... I- I die and learn, you know?
It's just the ghost way.
By the boxes?
Oh, there!
I see, I see.
Okay.
Ah!
Thank you.
Thanks, guys!
We have a lot of stuff in there.
Hey, y'all.
Station 12, come in.
Station- This is Station 8.
We heard 12 go down and out.
Surgical strike units are targeting railway stations.
Repeat.
Civil protection is coming down on underground stations.
We're already getting refugees from Nine and Outline.
Looks like we're- Station 8, do you copy?
Station 8, do you copy?
Oh, I just realized my flashlight also uses power.
Station 8, are you there?
Crazy.
Bill, thank you so much!
We have confirmed reports of manhacks.
Manhacks.
What's a manhack?
Uh-oh.
They're filling the underground with- With what?
You'll find out.
Sorry, I keep saving now.
Because I'm scared.
That's what they were using.
Bastards.
I was like, why are they shooting so hard?
Hope I didn't need that.
Yeah!
Oh, it doesn't shoot that far.
Um...
Ah!
Got my gun!
Wait, oh shoot.
I'm stuck.
Kinda
like blowing up everything.
Okay.
I was hoping that they would blow up the debris, you know?
So I could get through.
But I don't think that's the case.
Why is it goopy?
Yip!
I can't, I don't know how to use the ladders yet!
The planks.
Okay, hold on.
Let me loop again.
We'll loop a loop.
The planks, Minky!
Where are the planks?
Why can't I ever see the planks?
Oh, that right there, I see, I see.
Okay, we're running.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not good at using these stinking ladders.
Okay.
Up.
Over.
Here we go.
And we're running.
We're running.
I see!
Thanks, guys!
Oh!
You sick.
Oh my gosh.
I have to be careful.
Hello?
Please go walk through.
Why can't I crouch and walk?
There we go.
You're sick.
You're sick!
Oh.
I think I have to kill this one.
Die?
I sound so gross.
Soul.
Midnight.
Where?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna stay here in case any others come through.
Gotta keep the railway alive.
Aww.
Be safe in there, though.
Jump scare.
She's over here!
I'm right next to you!
Like...
Booty shot!
That doesn't look open.
Will I dive?
Oh my gosh!
I'm waiting for suspect.
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Surely the water will...
Um...
Wait...
The water will protect me, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
My oxygen is...
Oh my gosh.
Jump!
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
Holy...
Hold on, I gotta let my power restore.
Oh my gosh!
I just hear them everywhere.
Explosives and water will kill from a lot further because it is incompressible.
Yeah, don't listen to video games, guys.
Weird that your air and your flashlight use the same meter.
I'm not a huge fan of it at the moment, but, you know, I'm sure we'll... Eventually.
I don't like rushing because I'm blind and I don't know where to go.
I don't see, you know, see well.
So, I don't always... I don't like to rush.
Oops!
I didn't know you were up there!
Sorry, mister!
Oh, shoot.
Come on!
Oh, shoot!
Do I go up?
Or through here?
Oh,
okay.
I understand what I must do now.
Oh, he spat it out.
Then he spat it out.
Oh, he just keeps... they just keep grabbing that guy.
Oh my god, this is messed up.
Wait, this is so messed up!
Wait, okay, hold on.
I gotta push these somehow.
Okay, push you.
And then we'll blow them up.
Okay, wait.
Oh, they're so lightweight.
Okay, someone will grab it.
That one, right there, going down.
Going in for the kill!
Oops, now my depth reception is a little off.
Okay, one more.
It dodged every single one.
Here we go.
Um, that should be good enough.
Oh.
Good enough.
Maybe.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, maybe not good enough.
Wait, what's reload?
Um, what's...
Hey, buddy.
I don't need to reload.
We'll just send every...
I can't pick up that guy one on.
Run.
That was close.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean reload like the gun.
Sorry.
I'm gonna reload my save.
But thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, that was my... That was my wording.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my God.
Okay, but I need you to blow this up, maybe.
Ouch.
Okay, don't blow it up.
Oh my God.
I need to run.
And...
Jump.
Oh, I missed.
Oh.
Please.
I have no stamina.
Wait.
There's... There's a ladder.
I see it.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Everybody.
Don't panic.
We're not panicking.
Oh my God.
No.
Dead man.
Man down, man.
We're not panicking.
Right, everyone?
Oh my God.
I'm where?
Scum.
I don't know where that came from.
Thank you.
I'm stuck.
Oh my God.
Oh.
Oh, I see it.
Holy.
We made it.
Donkey Kong Ash level.
Let's see.
Over there.
We'll get there, everybody.
Okay, yeah.
Oh, I need these.
Okay.
Oh, this is kind of fun.
Wait.
Okay, we'll put that there for now.
You're a surprise, y'all.
Okay.
I picked them up like they're nothing though.
My realism.
Flip.
Oh.
I did press space.
I promise you.
While water would make the explosions much worse, the water would absolutely slow the bullets down.
Don't worry about it.
The physics.
And...
Is it me?
Am I...
Is my timing wrong?
Needs more bricks.
Am I going down and I don't realize?
Oh, this looks like a secret.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
We're safe.
We're zooming.
Oh shit, that's not an open door.
Oh, that's evil.
That's so evil.
Oh my god.
Please move.
Thank you for the super job.
Thank you for the pig.
Zen wildlife has pretty much made Earth their home.
Aw.
Woof.
She's too good.
Don't I know it, baby?
Intense.
Let me know also if like the volume ever starts getting kind of funky, you know?
Hold on.
Maybe I won't mess this one up.
What is that?
Is that a person?
Is that an enemy?
When it's like right here.
Dang it.
Still not.
Maybe I can't get closer because I think I'm going to fall.
It's like a trap.
Dying.
Don't shoot?
Just let it eat it.
Oh, does that work?
Oh, it did work.
Oh yeah, because they're shorter.
Okay.
I thought that they would disappear, the lines.
Okay, so we have...
Down here...
I could go to...
Which if I do go down, I don't know how to get back up.
So I don't want to go down just yet.
And we have this...
Really crispy guy!
Holy!
There is a ladder?
Did I miss it?
I don't know why I'm so...
I'm extremely blind with this game, you guys.
Holy cannoli.
Oh, it's a symbol!
I thought it was a...
What's the word?
A little wheel you turn.
I'm really blind today!
What's wrong with me?
Aw, sorry mister.
Yeah, Valve!
This is why I don't do stream so early.
Crispy.
I'm just too stupid.
I'm too stu...
I'm too tired to think.
Crispy.
Holy crispy.
I think I need this though.
For the other ones.
Crispy bacon.
He's our man.
But there's more.
Or...
There were more?
Did they all die?
No, I see it.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, so I'm just gonna let it eat it.
And see what happens.
You sons of bitches.
Sons of bitches!
Chat!
Okay.
Go up.
Wait, I see another one.
Oh, there's some physics happening.
Oh, they're shooting at me.
There's not physics at all.
Oh, they are aiming at me.
At the moment.
Okay, anyway.
Ignore them.
Another crispy person.
So many crispy people around here.
Okay, so this one we can...
This one...
We can throw and let the first guys eat.
And I will blow it up.
Ow, did that hurt me too?
I think it did actually.
Oh, wait.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Okay.
Good, good stuff, good stuff.
Good stuff.
Alright, good stuff, good stuff.
Ugh.
Now, I run.
Alright, well, I just saved, so...
Um...
Guys, do I go left?
Or right?
Let's go left.
Crispy.
This is not...
Ammo?
Give me?
I'm full.
Ugh.
Scared me.
Place seems haunted.
No secret behind the door.
Recently booked a trip to Japan.
What the?
See, dudes...
Since it'll be your first time.
Um...
Oh gosh.
Nothing...
Uh...
Just...
Go do whatever you want.
Uh...
Just have a good time.
If you wanna go do something, go check it out.
Ugh.
Sorry.
My brain is...
My brain cannot really answer because I am...
I am on overload right now.
Hahaha.
I apologize for the non-answer.
Anything?
Are we almost there?
To the lab?
Please.
Uh...
Get off your turn.
Civil protection is onto us.
We're tearing down the railroad.
Covering our tracks.
Oh.
Looks like you're gonna be the last one through.
I'm sorry, I'm just...
You're glad you're not the guy they're looking for.
Poor bastard doesn't stand a chance.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, poor him, right?
Uh-oh.
This is a man hack?
You're welcome.
Don't put that down.
Man hack.
You don't like me.
Where's the supplies?
Give me anything?
Give me something.
I saved your life.
Saved your life, mister.
What's better against those guns or...
The crowbar.
Up on top.
Get up there.
Mister.
Mister, why you gotta make it so difficult for me, huh?
Use your arms.
Use your arms, Gordon Freeman.
Reach.
Reach for the sky.
Wait, I'm trying to just see what else is up here.
I don't know how to turn things.
I know how to pick them up, but I don't know how to turn them.
Okay, I think...
I don't see anything else.
I think we're good.
Okay.
See you later, mister.
You go on.
Shut the hell up.
He's got a nice little setup up here, right?
Okay, mister.
Hold on.
Let me just take your staff.
Oops.
My bad.
Thank you.
Aw, you're so nice.
They'll break open the door for me.
Come on in!
Hello?
Where is he?
I didn't hear him scream.
Is he okay?
No!
Did they get him?
That's so messed up!
My god!
Okay, but he didn't tell me where the ladder was.
So, also...
Feeling a little bit vindicated.
Holy cow.
That doesn't seem good.
Taking one step at a time.
Anybody in here?
No?
Okay.
Hmm...
Guys...
Outside is so scary.
That's what I'm learning from this game.
I'm in here.
Are you one of the crispy guys?
Oh, I thought that was...
Okay.
I think I just need to get to the other side.
I just gotta be fast about it.
I don't wanna go outside.
What is that?
I think I hear...
Some...
I hear one of them, I think.
What's that on the ceiling?
Oh.
I think it's pipes.
It's a vent.
The vent has goodies.
Do they always like...
Oh my goodness.
Oh!
Goodies you say!
I see!
You are all tricksters.
What?
Oh, does this door not open?
Okay.
I see!
Little tricksters you all are!
Okay.
What a strange layout.
Oh!
I wonder when I'll get something other than a pistol.
Oh my god!
Okay, good.
I saw some of you being so rude in the chat and yelling.
Don't shoot it three times!
Only shoot it two!
But if I shoot it three times and it explodes immediately.
Chat backseating.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
I can't aim for shit.
Happened already!
How exciting!
It's not even the same number for this one.
I already got a new gun!
Fancy that.
Hello, mister.
This was such a good hiding...
Ah!
Shut up.
Oh my god, not my flashlight.
Ah!
Lady Saffron, thank you so much for the...
For the...
For the rain, thank you!
My flashlight went out.
Gross!
Oh gross!
Wait, I got grenades!
Okay.
One, two...
My SMG.
Wait, five is the grenade.
Okay.
Oh sh...
Why did I do that?
I didn't realize...
Wait.
I clicked three though!
Did I just lose my grenade?
I just lost the grenade.
Oops.
Look at more guys!
It's fine!
Look at more!
Oh, this sucks a little...
Um...
Did I go under?
Over?
What is breaking?
Oh, I see, I see.
It's like one of those...
Hotel...
You know?
Through...
Where?
There...
Um...
Is there a hole?
I...
I think I'm too fat to go through there.
Yeah, one of those hotel doors...
You know?
That always spin around...
I always would get so excited for those as a kid.
Is there a ladder that I'm missing?
There wouldn't be...
Cause there's nowhere to go out.
Do I spin on top of you?
Keep looking, you'll find it.
A key!
I trust!
I found.
Wait, which way did I come from?
We did!
We managed to avoid drowning.
Little bastard.
My eyes.
I know, I hate this thing the most.
It's so horrible.
So how's the volume, you guys?
I know...
I think I asked before and then I...
I'm gonna go back to our pistol.
Is it okay?
Is it loud?
I think it's gonna be loud cause I'm shooting guns.
So I apologize.
Beep, beep.
I'm just gonna shoot him.
Come on.
That's right.
Ugly.
I want to look out there.
Wait.
Go.
Oh wait.
I think I have to go out there.
Just kidding.
Game tricked me.
Oh shoot.
Did you just throw a grenade?
No, she threw a...
One of these.
Can I...
Oh, I was gonna say...
I don't think I can get over here, dummy.
Your man hacker.
Wait.
Okay, from here...
Do I need to...
Aha!
I see, I see, I see!
I understood the assignment.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Um...
What is that?
Flying over there.
I like the way they try to chew it.
They're just like, disgusting.
Disgusting.
Okay, I think I can blow them up with a...
If I give them one of these.
Wait.
Wait!
Oh!
Uh...
Sure.
Guys!
Some very needed...
Everything.
Good job, team.
I'm gonna bring this guy out.
Just in case.
Okay, I'm...
Guessing I can't get hit by this team.
Or else it...
Hoorts me.
And that guy's waiting for me.
Look at him!
Stalking me!
Let me go, thank you!
I'm watching you!
And he's watching me.
And I'm watching him.
He's even...
This is serious.
I could shoot it.
That is true.
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Why are you so mean?
What are you talking about?
He wants to...
He wants to peel me like an apple!
Whatever.
Oh, wait.
Now I'm inside the room, aren't I?
I sure hope he doesn't notice.
Find all Lambda caches in Half-Life 2.
What does that mean?
When I'm doing that.
Justice for manhack!
What about me?
The symbols.
I don't even see where I found it.
Like, I see this guy, but...
Ah, here we go.
That's tricky.
In we go!
Oh!
Aha!
I should get my gun out.
And...
Oh my god.
Just run!
Ow!
Oh!
Oh my god, they can hit me!
They can hit me!
Oh gosh!
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
Are they just gonna keep coming in?
Or... wait, can I... towards, you know, the very obvious light that's right next to me.
And then, this is a... there's this.
I'm just gonna sit in a corner and let them come to me!
Yeah, I see... I see the very problematic, um... reason not to shoot in this room.
I understand.
Very much.
Come at me.
Okay.
I imagine... that is it.
For now.
Okay.
Golly.
There's something up there.
But...
It's not where I came from.
Hmm.
I don't think I can get up there.
Shoot the barrels!
Okay!
Wait, if I just use the barrels here...
If I could somehow stack them...
I wish I could rotate them.
Oh, here we go.
I have to rotate them...
Very...
Carefully.
Like...
Too early?
Actually...
Maybe it'll work.
Nevermind.
It don't...
It doesn't.
I'm overthinking it, am I?
That's me.
Minky the overthinker.
I could just stack these guys.
How do I get up there?
I have to keep stacking them.
Explodes barrel.
But please respond!
Answer me!
Minky!
Her massive brain is wearing her down!
How so?
What am I doing?
Oopsie.
What about the ladder?
I don't think it goes up to anywhere unless I like...
Unless I jump onto the pipes.
No, I don't want to go down.
I want to see what's over there.
That's all.
I know...
I feel like I need to go down, but I don't want to go down just yet.
Is what I'm saying.
Oh, there we go!
I just want to see what's over here.
I like to explore, everybody.
Sorry if that annoys you.
It's how I play game.
I like walking everywhere and seeing everything.
It's how I like to do.
Actually, I don't know which way was supposed to be the correct way anymore.
Wait.
I hate the ladder so much.
Like, I know it's E to dismount, but I just don't get it right.
Ah!
This is...
Okay, okay, okay.
So we're basically just on the other side of where we were going to go.
Minky Dog Explorer.
Sorry, Stretch.
Let's see.
What do we got going on in this room?
I guess we can go see what is on the other side as well.
Ah!
Thank you.
Thank you, Box.
Ladder.
Water through.
Wait.
No, that's just shadows.
I thought this might be like a...
A hole to crawl through.
Okay, so we checked over here.
Now we go down.
How am I supposed to get in here though?
Hmm, curious.
Papers, thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you!
Oh.
Oh, come on.
No, please don't do this to me.
Wait.
Who sabotaged the ladder?
Wait, please.
Oh my God.
Wait.
Okay.
We're fine.
What the heck?
So funny.
Okay, I think everything that we need to do is over on this side then.
But what?
Oh.
Oh my goodness, guys.
I don't know why I've been having such bad headaches recently.
Oh, give me one second.
Hmm.
NYC debuff.
I came back from New York and...
Gosh.
It messed me up.
Is that me?
Um...
I was fine until just now.
It all just...
It just came...
At once.
Um...
Uh...
Pipes.
Anything with the pipes.
The pipes.
Why does it gotta be pipes?
Um...
Oh!
There's more health down there.
Break time?
I'm...
Um...
I might go get...
Some medicine.
It's...
Right...
Right behind my eye.
Where it's like...
Just a surge of spiritual energy.
She fulfilled the prophecy.
She escaped from New York.
It's true!
If you get those kinds of headaches, you know they're like...
They're such a pain.
Um...
Uh...
Saw your ghost migraine and wanted to try...
Cap...
Oh...
Um...
Yeah, I've...
I...
Have had...
Migraines...
For as long as I've been dead.
So...
Um...
Only a couple things work for me.
But I appreciate it.
That...
Uh...
People that try to help...
Out and everything.
Only a couple things...
Really work for me.
So...
Since I've...
I've had them...
For a long, long time!
Hehehehe.
It's all good though.
Imagine it as your latent psychic powers.
I'm...
Do I...
I don't think I can be psychic.
I'm a ghost.
Hehehehe.
Hmm...
But...
I appreciate it.
I appreciate it when people are like...
Oh, maybe try this, try that.
I've tried a lot, a lot of things.
And um...
You know, I kinda know what works for me.
And how I am able to...
Ah!
How I am able to handle them now.
You know?
So...
There we goooood!
Oh, we're still going.
Okay.
There we keep going.
Alright.
Here we are.
Still going.
Hehehehe.
Is there another one?
Nope, it's still going.
Uh...
But this just...
Oh wait!
But it probably...
Oh, it raised it in the other room too then.
Yahoo!
Okay.
Oh, now I'm stuck.
Hehehehe.
Have you tried removing your brain?
Putting it in the dishwasher.
Do you have a brain?
You have a brain to remove?
Uh oh.
I knew it.
I heard them.
I heard you!
Yeah!
Oh!
Wasn't me.
Wasn't me!
I think someone shot...
In the room.
I have a sneaking suspicion that somebody...
Shot a gun.
Or...
The man hacks.
Oh!
They're all gone!
Oh, the barrels are gone!
Let's go.
Hehehehe.
I didn't even have to lift a finger.
The real...
Oh!
Wait.
No!
I go down.
Sorry, my bad.
I forgot.
Real princess treatment over here.
Hehehe.
Get away!
What is that?
Oh, just a red light.
Okay.
Alright.
Anything down here?
Some boxes?
Maybe with some loot?
Oh.
Hold on.
I don't want my oxygen to run out.
Oh gosh!
Oh my gosh!
That does a lot of damage!
Holy damage!
Wow!
Okay, but it goes back up.
Okay, good, good, good.
Goodness!
Wait.
Maybe if I...
Let it...
Okay, it's...
Dang it, it doesn't float.
I thought it said we all float down here.
What happened?
Okay.
Yeah, it's temporary damage.
That's nice.
Okay.
We all floatin'.
I'm floatin', I'm floatin'.
Cool.
Wait, wait.
Uh, uh.
Why am I sinking?
Uh, uh, please.
And I...
Jump.
Jump?
Hello?
Oh?
I'll float on.
Alright.
I'll...
I'll float on.
B...
How'd you jump this situation?
Oh.
Why am I not floating?
Duck jump.
Hey!
Oh!
We did a team!
We did it!
Do
I have my gun out or what?
Nothing here.
Oh my gosh.
Gosh!
You son of a bitch.
Now all of China knows you're here.
Which way do I go, though?
I think I fall onto that.
Wait, does the water break my fall like in Minecraft?
Or... Is that not a thing?
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh!
We got him.
Oh, don't alert the guards, please.
Please.
Oh, wait.
Is this the gun where if I press right click, it shoots like the grenade?
I see the alt on the bottom.
Sorry that I'm... Hold on, guys.
I'm so sorry.
I think I'm gonna have to go get some headache medicine real quick.
Random tips.
Small marked boxes will be the only boxes with supplies.
You'll have to get used to seeing them.
Oh, okay.
Headcrabs and barnacles will die in one hit with a crowbar.
Really?
We don't go to Ravenholm.
I don't know what that means, but...
Oh!
I'm so sorry.
Let me go.
I just... I think I can just take one and I'll be okay.
I'll just... Sorry.
I'm like... I'm... I'm... I'm winking at you guys.
Ow!
Okay, I'll be right... I'm sorry.
I'll be right back.
Hey,
I'm back.
Sorry about that.
Little... Little intermission we shall have.
I got medicine, which I will take when my tea cools down a bit.
And I've got Cheez-Its!
Cheez-Its!
Cheez-Its as a snack.
Yippee!
Too much thinking?
I... I think I know what it is.
I think.
I think so.
So...
The flavor...
Just regular old Cheez-Its.
The original.
Mm-hmm.
So...
Um...
Yeah, I think I know.
It's all good.
Once a month, the bridge...
The gap from the spiritual world and the...
And the human realm becomes very muddled.
And so...
Yeah.
Going through a very...
You know, a...
A...
Tumultuously...
A tumultuous spiritual time right now.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh my gosh, wait!
Did you guys know that there's...
It's not a supermoon tonight.
But...
It's...
Um...
It's something else.
It's a different kind of moon.
Where...
Because a supermoon is when, like, the gravitate...
Where it's actually, like, close to Earth.
But today...
Um...
Oh, what was it?
Ugh.
It's...
But the moon will look really, really big.
So you guys should go look at it.
Oh, yes!
The sturgeon moon!
It's the sturgeon moon!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Ha ha ha ha!
You guys should...
Check it out.
The sturgeon moon tonight.
Mm-hmm.
Ha ha ha.
It was...
It was, uh...
Named that way from...
Uh...
I think it was, like, Native Americans named it that.
Because it always occurred during a time when, like, the sturgeon fish were...
Were...
Uh...
Reproducing and stuff.
So...
Mm.
Yeah.
So...
Check out the moon tonight.
It's not a supermoon.
Supermoon is when the moon is actually closer.
Hold on.
I'm gonna look it up, because I can't remember.
Uh-oh.
Stur...
Sturgeon moon.
Mm-mm-mm.
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
Du-du-du-du.
Where was it?
I guess...
Because it...
Because I know, like, with, uh...
Supermoon, like, the...
It's actually closer to Earth.
But not in this case.
But yeah, it's tonight.
Teehee.
Any sturgeons in chat?
I noticed that last night it's been looking pretty big.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cool.
I like it.
And if it starts...
It starts to...
Like, make it feel like it's spooky time, you know?
Teehee.
Starting to feel...
Especially when the moon gets orange and...
And everything.
Supermoon is...
Closer to Earth and aligned with the sun.
I like space.
Looking forward to...
To fall.
Hold on, let me write snack time.
Or, like, little break.
Sorry, guys.
Little break.
That's me.
A little break.
Mogu mogu.
And then, I think...
There's, like, a...
There's, like, a meteor shower that's happening...
Soon.
I can't remember the date.
I think it's next week.
Uh...
Basically, a big ol' big ol' meteor that's passing by us...
It breaks off a little bit.
And it causes, like, a ton of...
A ton of, you know...
Little tiny meteor showers.
So much space stuff happening.
I don't know!
Oh!
Do you guys remember that?
Geeks plays in your comment room.
Remind me.
Do you guys remember that?
I think it was a vine back then.
The girl that was just, like, playing as her little skit.
The skit.
She's an angel and she's God.
And she's like, Hey, God, what's up?
And God's like, Hey!
Did you, um...
Did you...
Did you give the...
The dinosaurs that present I asked you?
And the angel goes, Yeah!
I made them...
I made them a meteor.
And he said, You made them meteor.
She goes, Yeah!
I made them a meteor.
And he says, Meteor.
Like...
I told you to make them meteor.
Meteor.
And she said, A meat.
And then the angel goes, A meteor.
More meaty.
Do you guys remember that?
It's such a funny skit.
And then the whole time she's like, Tearing up on you.
She's like, I told you to make the meteor.
It's so funny.
Never heard of it.
You have to look it.
You have to look it up.
I'm not doing it justice at all.
Making the dinosaurs meteor.
Sounds too long to be a vine.
How long were vines?
Did you guys ever make any vines?
My glasses are hot.
Thanks.
I'm...
I'm nerding out today.
Six seconds!
Whoa.
I'm not good with like...
Especially videos.
I'm surprised I stream.
Because I never like mid...
Like...
Vines.
I never make TikToks.
I barely even post videos to like...
Twitter or anything.
I...
Um...
Hold on, K-Barn.
Well, I'll read it in just a second.
I just...
I...
I really...
Never made so...
Like...
You know like...
Some people will like...
Just take videos of themselves with their friends.
I never did that.
I just...
I just never did anything.
Meh.
War drop what I eat.
The Combine's deal is they conquer and enslave other species...
Then improve them with cybernetics and add them to their army.
The Zen invaders from Half-Life 1 were fleeing from Combine and led them to Earth.
Ah!
Okay, that's why they're here.
I do remember that...
We went to Zen and we saw all those poor guys that were...
That were enslaved and...
I wasn't supposed to shoot them and I did on accident.
Dr. Cranberry!
Thank you so much for that.
Super chat for my favorite game ever.
Fun fact, this game and Snake Eater were released in the same year.
2004 was goaded.
Wow!
And you know what?
Both look so amazing.
Gosh.
The early 2000s...
It's so...
I get sad about like...
And I know other people think about this too sometimes.
About like how with gaming...
We've reached...
So many peaks in such a short amount of time.
That it's like...
You know...
We'll never kind of experience that again in a way.
Like...
We'll never be able to see this...
This...
Evolution of...
Of...
The craft in front of our eyes.
It's kind of crazy.
Like...
VR is the only thing...
I guess...
Yeah...
I mean...
Obviously there's still places to go.
But like...
Everybody keeps striving for more and more realism.
And...
I'm like...
No!
Stylization is so much better than realism.
Please!
I'm a realism hater.
I'm like...
I can see when it's good.
Like I understand.
But...
At the same time...
Hey Minky...
Will you possibly play...
Half-Life Alyx after this in VR?
Possibly with your 3D.
Is it long?
Because if it's not too long...
I think I could do it.
But I've never done like a...
Like a shooter...
In...
VR...
Yeah...
Realism has it's place.
But...
Usually I'm just like...
Style...
Stylistic...
Make it...
Make it look...
So many games just all look the same now!
Cause they're all just like...
Hi...
I'm a realistic looking lady.
I'm a realistic looking man.
And I can't tell!
The graphics all look the same!
Ugh...
You should 100% play Expedition 33.
I've heard a lot of good stuff about it.
Kiwawa was super into it.
Unfortunately my lunch break is over!
Have a good day!
Thanks for dropping by!
Ooh Nan...
You're throwing punches there.
Kojima was jealous of Half-Life when making MGS2.
Wait, is that real?
I can't tell if it's real or not.
Every game should be Ace Combat.
Half-Life Alyx is 12 hours!
12 hour game...
In VR?
That's pretty rough.
I'm not gonna lie.
I just re-watched your tour of the V Shoujo Minecraft server.
Was obvious back then that you were joining?
No!
Actually I don't think I was back then.
Wait, when did I stream that?
I don't think I was.
I don't think I had decided yet.
I do just like to hang out with the girlies sometimes.
You know, I love Henya.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
A second Exhibition 33...
Isn't it turn-based?
I hate...
Sorry, I hate turn-based...
Even though I'm not like...
I don't have the...
The...
The reflexes for...
For just action stuff.
I just...
I don't know.
Not a big turn-based fan.
Turn-based, but with timing...
Timing-based dodging.
I see.
Except for Pokemon.
That's so true!
For some reason, Pokemon doesn't feel like turn-based to me.
Even though it's the definition.
What about Metal Gear Acid?
Why do you think I haven't played it yet?
Also, because it's...
Turn-based and cards.
It's like the worst combination ever.
I hated turn-based before I played Baldur's Gate 3.
I think I would be fine with it now.
I think I would be okay with it now.
I think maybe I was...
Hmm.
Because I played Final Fantasy as a kid.
And I was like...
Yeah.
And then I played Kingdom Hearts.
I think that's what happened.
I played Final Fantasy.
And then I played Kingdom Hearts and I was like...
I was like...
And Kingdom Hearts is so easy.
It's so friendly for like...
For...
For me.
I hope you one day check out Bayonetta.
I was talking to Maddie about Bayonetta.
Because...
We were talking about DMC and Bayonetta.
And...
She was saying how she went from Bayonetta to DMC.
And how...
She was so used to...
How...
How Bayonetta is like so...
Flowy.
And smooth.
And light.
And then Dante is heavy, heavy, heavy.
So maybe.
Feel like you may have mentioned before.
But will you be going to the Holo EN concert at the end of August?
Unfortunately, no.
Sad, no.
I...
I had a really great time at HoloFest.
HoloExpo.
I don't remember how they word theirs.
Because I was able to see the screen.
I...
I went to one of the shows.
I went to the one...
Um...
At, uh...
Anime Week in Atlanta.
And I couldn't see anything the entire time.
And I was like...
It was, uh...
I literally couldn't see...
I...
I would see Kiara's hat sometimes.
So...
You know...
But...
Um...
Yeah...
But, um...
Also, isn't it...
It's during Anime NYC, no?
I think that's the same weekend as MGS Con, which I will be at.
I'm a guest at MGS Con.
So...
Flo, easy fix.
I don't want to be obvious.
I don't want people to be like, Oh, that girl's floating right there.
Like...
It's AMYC weekend.
But not affiliated.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Hmm.
Guest of honor.
I'm a guest of honor.
They sent me my schedule for things that I'm doing.
Uh...
MGS Con.
You will see me...
Several times...
Throughout the day if you are going.
Hehehe.
Yeah.
So...
Okay.
Um, let me take my medicine now.
And then I will...
Actually, it feels better.
Maybe the salt is helping.
Hmm.
Sorry, I'm really bad at taking pills.
At MGS Con, I am doing things online.
I think actually everything that I have going on will also be online.
I think it's...
Supposed to be digi...
Part of the digital con and also...
Uh...
Minus one thing.
I think there's one thing that's digital exclusive.
But everything else should be...
Also both at...
At the convention and then also...
Online.
Hehehe.
Still obvious.
Whatever you say, buddy.
But...
Uh...
There's a lot of people on the...
On the Minecraft server.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Okay.
Um...
Very important fan told about MGS Con.
Hehehe!
I have a digital ticket!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, virtual stream.
It should be fun.
Um...
I'm very excited for it.
I'm very excited.
Okay.
I'm back.
I'm back at the game.
Okay.
Minky Gaiman.
So...
Oh, this...
This says supply.
So...
There's nothing in it.
Oh, wait.
No, I gotta charge.
Just kidding.
Oh, don't break my boxes!
I like to do that part!
I just stand here and I...
Okay, I'm gonna save because I don't know...
Where I saved...
Hey!
The music in this one is so...
Kinda freaky.
This game feels like a horror game for real.
Oh!
Oh, yeah.
You got that one.
I got some.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to take off my break.
Teehee.
There we go.
I drank a second so much for the 20 games and thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm letting my...
Ox power...
Power up.
Okay, take that.
Take that.
Wait.
Take that?
You want that?
Oh, no.
Why don't you take it?
Okay, anyway.
It was in here.
I like...
Uh...
That...
That one looks a little messier than the other symbols that we've been seeing.
Is it a fake?
Will they do that to trick you?
Okay, so we go in there.
He said icky.
Meow.
I once saw...
A symbol...
What's it called?
The lamb...
Lambda symbol?
I once saw it...
Like, when I was taking a walk.
And I was like...
What?
I was like...
Whoa!
I...
Why is half-life happening here?
Just like half-life.
I know!
I was actually...
I was...
I was noting out.
How do I get down there?
Was there a ladder and I missed it?
Did you just say nerd?
It is down...
Wait.
Yeah.
That's not a door.
I don't wanna fall and break my legs.
Leap of faith.
Oh.
Easy.
I think I...
Oh, it's the goo!
Radiation goo.
The Geiger count.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
What?
Alright.
Um...
I believe I know what I need to do.
Oh, here?
I...
I don't think I need to go in there.
I feel like I have to follow the symbols.
So I do this.
Oh, no!
There's just a friend here!
Aw, friend!
I'm sorry!
I'm full on literally everything too.
Unfortunate.
Do I go through then?
I'm going in?
I'm going in the sludge.
Wow.
There's so much here.
I'm sorry, buddy.
Can I pick you up?
No.
Okay.
How am I supposed to not touch the wet goo if I need to go in there?
There is dry goo.
Wait.
So this is dry?
Oh, no.
This is wet.
This...
How does radiation levels...
This is dry goo.
Got it.
Head crabs!
Oh.
Hey!
Hi!
You're Freeman, aren't you?
Yes!
We got word you were coming.
You got here at a bad time.
Black Mesa East to station six.
Do you read?
Dr. Freeman is on his way down.
You can.
Repeat.
Gordon Freeman has returned.
It's at East.
Dang, they like me or something.
We've got some ammo in those crates over there.
Whoa!
What about in here?
I'm sorry.
I broke your thing.
Okay.
So that's the wet.
Here we go.
You hate this part?
Oh, boy.
Okay.
That means I'll probably hate it, too.
I'm going.
Now this part rocks.
Oh my god!
Oh, come on.
Oh no.
Oh, you guys have one hit for the headcrab, right?
Are they in the ground?
Oh,
okay.
Definitely, I'm gonna use my crowbar.
Holy cow.
Oh wow, their little town.
Get smacked.
Okay, nothing around over here.
Alright.
I'm starting to see the crates with the supply marker on it.
I am.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
See, that one doesn't have it.
I'm learning.
No!
Wait, can I shoot it?
I saved you!
Maybe.
I hear wood.
I hear it like stomping around.
Come here!
What am I hearing?
I'm hearing something going...
Kinda freaked out.
Chill out.
I don't...
Since...
Oh!
Okay!
Oh gosh, he's really stupid.
He's dumb, he's dumb!
I don't think it's the Geiger counter.
I can't tell what it is.
He's that...
He's such a stupid little thing.
That's okay.
I like him stupid.
Oh...
I got baited in that one.
Okay.
Electric wire, maybe?
Oh, scary!
Oh my god!
Wait, don't scare me!
Holy cow!
That scared me!
Oh, I don't like it.
Oh, that's the guy that was sitting over there.
I did see him.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
This is horrible!
Where are you?
I hear you!
Oh, there you are.
Nevermind.
There you aren't.
Jump!
The headcrabs are so silly.
They're cracking me up.
Oh no, wait!
This is evil!
Okay, I have to...
Run!
And be careful.
Ouch, ouch!
That was more effective than my god.
Why?
Um, can I go through there, or...
We...
...clobbered.
Why?
Because Gordon's strong!
Pistol is so weak, I should just start using my...
SMG.
I do have a lot of ammo for it.
Okay.
We on crate.
This...
Hey!
Wait, did that hit me?
Stop!
Stop moving!
Don't move.
Don't close.
Oh, ouch.
Okay, okay, okay.
It really does hurt me.
Okay.
Oh, the smoke.
You're gonna get electrocuted.
Oh, I missed one.
One guy buried.
You're in the radiation, idiot!
Ouch.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Guys.
Okay, hold on.
There was a health in here.
I can grab it.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're good.
Oh, I lost everything for my suit.
Everything is...
Ah!
Everything is terrible!
Move.
You're throwing off my groove.
That way.
Why did they live here?
Oh, yes.
I love living by the hazardous waste.
Rent is cheap.
Fair.
Oh, they're letting me use the boat.
That's right.
He was filling it up.
Hey, Dr. Freeman.
Hi!
I've been hoping you'd show up.
Got this airboat all gassed up and ready to go.
All your friends are dead.
It's gonna be tough dodging civil protection out there in the open.
Oh, gosh.
Drive hard and you'll make it.
I have just...
Okay.
Just a few bends up the river.
It's the old red barn.
The old red barn.
Climb on in.
Fire her up.
All your friends are dead!
Okay.
Go ahead and get in the boat, Dr. Freeman.
I'm scared.
I don't think I'm gonna do it.
Okay.
So I just gotta dodge, right?
Speed.
Slow down.
Turn left.
Okay.
See you later, lady.
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
Wait.
Beep!
Alright.
Wait, this is kinda fun.
Beep!
Where do I go?
Here?
This looks like it should open.
No?
Okay, just kidding.
No hands.
That's how I always do it, baby!
Speed!
Seven point turn.
Can you drink the funny water?
Probably.
I
gotta open it myself.
Okay.
I think I see where I open it.
I think I see what I... Okay.
So I like go up...
Oh.
Golly.
Okay.
Um.
Can I drive on the land?
I was just gonna get out.
Oh.
This is the... Land bu... Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't think you can drive on the land.
Guys.
Uh-oh.
Guys, I don't know if that's an option.
Okay.
Beep.
All right.
We're good.
Oh, no.
Please.
I came in hot.
Coming in hot.
I mean, though.
Oh.
Break.
I see you there.
You're not... You are not slick.
Where'd he go?
Yeah, ugly.
When did that happen?
Is there a button?
I thought it was gonna... Oh.
Absolutely.
No.
Oh.
Never mind.
Gootie.
Oh.
I don't think we take damage.
Water hazard.
One moment, please.
There's the red...
Look.
I used to... I used to not even see ladders.
And now, I'm a genius.
Now, I'm a genius.
Notice how low the water level is?
The com... The what?
Combine has been stealing our oceans.
Oh!
I'm seeing every ladder now.
Hack that.
In here?
It's quite peaceful out here, actually.
Oh.
I'm doing...
I'm doing flips.
Good day, Mean Dog.
It's a good one.
You too!
Hey!
Thank you.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
No, our team!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
You guys were supposed to help us!
I mean, us, me.
Ouch.
It's me.
Me.
All me.
All me, baby.
The royal we.
I always say we, usually, because I include you guys in my...
in my thought process.
It's like I like you guys or something.
I don't know.
Imagine that.
Should be one more, no?
Usually three...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Lacerations detected.
Rise and shine, Miss Phantom!
No,
this place was supposed to be free and easy.
There weren't supposed to be you guys here!
Wait, hello?
Get me off of this...
Uh uh...
This ladder, please.
Hello?
Why can't I move?
I keep just jumping back up.
Please get me off.
I don't want to go back up!
Jump?
I just...
I guess I have to go down this way.
I think I'm gonna break my...
My legs.
My legs!
Ah, okay.
Find all Lambda caches in Half-Life 2.
Lambda local.
I keep getting this achievement.
Ha ha ha!
I guess that's everything here, though, no?
Sad.
I really thought we'd have friends here.
Okay, we're full on everything else.
Oh!
Um...
I'll put you there.
It's progress.
Oh!
I didn't mean to blow it up.
Oh, I see!
Because of here!
Oh, I didn't blow it up.
Can you put it on the boat?
Great question.
Um...
I'll just leave it here.
Okay.
Alright!
Onwards!
Imagine anything going right in this...
Hellscape.
But if I don't have friends...
Where do I go?
They said go to the barn!
Oh!
Whoa!
Beep!
Supplies!
Oh!
Ouch!
Who said that?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Where is that thing?
Ah!
Leave me alone!
Another one!
Um...
Anyway...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Whoa...
Like a little mouse...
The paparazzi...
They are so rude!
No!
Oh!
I'm supposed to...
What's that sound?
Oh, it's suspicious.
That was suspicious.
It's puzzle?
Do I...
Okay, hold on.
Do I use these to...
Bounce off of?
Cause the issue was...
I got stuck.
So like...
Well, actually...
Oh, wait.
Aha!
Okay, this...
That needs to be...
Wait...
There's nothing in here.
What the...
Okay, hold on.
Hi-yah!
Okay.
Let's take...
You...
Um...
Crouch drop.
Now...
Down, boy!
Down!
Uh...
I need to get underneath...
Well, actually...
Oh...
Hmm...
It doesn't go the other way.
Thank you.
But I do see that it needs to go down...
To go up.
Oh, let's see.
Let's see now.
The stream is replenishing my life force after a tense work week.
Oh no, Sergey!
Can...
Can you make me smile in a way that clears the darkness in my very soul?
Oh, you can...
I thought you were asking me a question.
Can you do this for me?
I was like, wow, that's a pretty big offer, but...
That's a pretty big ask.
How do we do?
How do you do?
Okay, hold on.
Let's just collect these real quick.
If I want hint, I will ask.
But for now...
Let me...
Say.
For now, let me...
Does this one have to be in here?
No.
I already got a hint.
What?
Ow!
Are you talking about...
You're like, oh, well, VTuber, actually, I posted the answer...
Five minutes ago, and you didn't read it.
That was your hint.
VTuber, actually...
You just didn't see that I sent you the hint...
Or I sent you the answer.
That was your hint.
Wait time I read my hint.
It's okay, VTubers don't read.
Nah.
Never.
Actually, I find that like...
I guess it really just depends on the person.
I don't watch a ton of streamers.
But I...
And I mostly only follow...
VTubers.
But of the streamers that I watch, they don't really read chat that much.
I think it's a hindrance to me, in fact, that I pay so much attention to you guys.
Little needy.
But...
Because it...
Makes me miss stuff, you know?
Because I'm like...
I'm just chit-chatting with you guys.
Oh wait, maybe we didn't...
Oh, wow!
Who was that?
Oh, that was me.
We need more in here.
She got it?
Oh god!
I see what you mean by that was your hint.
Because I noticed too that it went down.
So I was like, uh-oh.
My big wrinkly brain.
You wanna talk about how wrinkly my brain is?
Perfect.
Back it up.
Is there anything over there?
That I missed?
Any supplies?
Who was the guy that yelled at me anyway?
I'm gonna do it.
All right.
Put your glasses on.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh.
Ssss.
Up.
There is a ramp!
Every dead end has a ramp!
Ha ha ha!
Nyaaaaaaah!
Aw, man.
I think I missed the supplies up there.
I just saw it.
Oh, I see more supplies up there!
I'm missing everything!
I'm just...
I'm kinda cruising, not gonna lie.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
Now that we're here, is there anything else to look for?
Missed those barnacles.
Yes, indeedy I did!
I have full health.
You're right.
I'm mostly looking for stuff for my suit.
Oh.
That's someone shooting at me.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Nice try, buddy.
Wait, can I, like, get him right here?
That's so funny.
I guess if you go for, like, an all-kill...
Open!
Sesame!
Open Sesame!
La, la, la,
la...
Wup!
All red broken!
Can't wait for the cover.
I think we found a power source.
They don't even have to...
Lock him up.
Nice.
Dang, this room is... You good?
Wake up.
Did you say romantic power?
Does he want to date me or something?
Oh my god.
He scared me.
He wants to date me or something.
Free man?
I guess I can't destroy... Is that a camera or a... It's not a turret.
Maybe it is.
It's a camera.
Grenade is five.
Okay, it didn't work.
That's fine.
Oh.
Does it... I guess it doesn't do anything?
Maybe.
I can't tell.
Scary!
I don't like it.
It does nothing?
Really?
That's kind of a shame.
I don't... I don't see you.
Wait.
There we go.
Ow!
Gosh!
Ah!
Man hack.
Can I get in through the door, please?
Where are they coming from?
Is that a man hack right there?
Oh, oh!
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Oh my gosh, that's cool.
So we need to feed them, you know.
Ah, neat, neat, neat.
What am I doing in here?
Opening the door.
This game is very generous with health and stuff.
Way more than before.
I know that I need to open the door.
Oh!
Not that one, but you know, the...
The one that we're trying to get through.
Ouch!
My aim.
I wish I could zoom and shoot.
Can I?
No.
I just shut the door.
They shut the door.
A ghost shut the door.
Okay.
Please!
Kill, kill!
It's so hard to see the...
My crosshairs.
They're so tiny.
Oh my god.
My crosshairs are so itty-bitty.
They want you to use the nades.
Ah, I guess that makes sense.
Because they just gave it to me.
Will it reach?
I didn't think it would.
Did I get him?
I think I heard him.
It's okay.
Oh, wow.
Nice checkpoint.
Okay.
Let's attempt.
Try the ult for this.
Oh, nice!
Oh, we are out of the ult.
So sad.
Like a pro.
Thanks, guys.
For the help.
I like these, like, gooey...
Walls that they have.
They're so fun.
Let's just throw.
Oh!
I wonder how many we got.
Actually, let's do another one.
I think he's coming up.
Nope.
Not even a single guy!
Is that everybody?
Hello?
Gosh.
This game is so generous.
One more.
Bottom right corner.
They should all be looking out for me.
They should all be scared.
So scared.
Frightened.
Shaking in their little booties.
Oh, I thought this was a ladder.
Just kidding.
Oh.
A ghost!
Are these the ones that I threw?
That's crazy.
Did I get your stuff, too?
Okay.
Thank you so much, motherfucker.
Thank you!
A-g-g-g-g.
A-g-g-g.
A-g-g-g-ghost!
Okay.
Uh, this way.
My bad.
Oh.
Do I blow it up?
Do I...
I don't think that I can blow up.
The radio calls are actually unique to the chapter and have a whole log of what they mean in our forest.
Seriously?
Use the crowbar and just stick it in there and...
Look around.
I'm looking!
I'm...
Do we have to get to the other side?
And then use this?
And have it go...
Okay.
Where the hell do I get to the other side?
You still have it right here?
You do?
See what happens.
Oh.
That's not good.
Oh, it did work!
Okay, I think we gotta go.
Uh...
Alarm does not sound good.
Oh, shit.
Golly!
Die, please.
Stop it!
Don't take my picture!
Ow!
I think I hear another one.
Oh my god.
Die!
I'm trying to take cover, please.
Oh, this is not good.
What?
What is that?
Any of them died.
That's so sad.
Turret to save ammo.
Oh wait, that's such a good idea!
I hate this thing.
I hate this thing so much.
I'm my heckin' life.
I think, uh...
I think the car is even moving.
Um, I think I destroyed that thing.
So...
That's nice, at least.
Oh, I did get a few guys!
Let's go.
I did grab a few.
I'm just gonna save.
Oh no.
Okay.
Um, and then we know...
I'm gonna bounce it off the wall.
Oops.
That did not have...
Nearly as much bounce as I thought it would.
It just...
Bang, bang!
I have nearly...
As much bounce...
As I thought it would.
That's a little embarrassing.
Ow!
Where did you come from?
Please die!
At least you have infinite source of grenades...
You're right!
I could grab some more.
Yes, yes.
And then there's the other guy over here.
Oh my goodness!
Maybe I'll just do this.
Yeah!
Oh, come on!
No!
This sucks.
Which way is he coming?
I got him.
Oh, there's another guy?
Two of them!
Three of them!
Four of them!
More of them.
Unlimited men.
Sorry, I keep going back in here.
I'm gonna grab more grenades.
We're just gonna keep grabbing grenades.
Aw, man.
You throw like a ghost!
Who's gonna tell him?
There's a guy here, right?
Got his stuff.
Grab their stuff.
Oh.
Is there anything else in here that I couldn't grab before?
Yes!
And even some health.
Okay, good, good, good.
Does he know?
You throw like a ghost girl!
Noice.
Okay, now I save.
Nice and peaceful over here.
Oh.
I guess I wasn't that big of a deal.
Excuse me?
There was stuff in there?
Very nice.
On the road again.
I can't wait to be young.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Break.
We're breaking free!
Ouch.
Oh, I did feel that.
Guys.
Um.
I don't know.
This part is hard.
Oh my gosh.
Holy golly golly golly.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Wait.
Ow!
Ah!
Oh.
What?
Oh my gosh.
A stinking...
Checkpoint.
What the hell?
Wait.
My health is like...
Not even...
Here to do this kind of...
Wait.
I see.
I see the ramp.
We are...
Okay.
Just go.
Holy cow.
Is this possible for me?
For my save?
Probably not.
Right?
I don't know.
And then I get burned.
Maybe not.
Maybe I'm sorry.
Maybe it's chill.
Maybe we're good.
Maybe everything's okay.
Oh.
That's not a hole.
Definitely thought it was.
Wait.
Hold on.
We can definitely parkour here.
We a hun...
Oh.
We a hundred percent can parkour here.
My health...
Is my own...
Concern.
I'm stupid at this stuff.
Wait.
Why can't I jump here?
Why do I have to go all the way around?
Let me just go here instead.
Okay.
Where am I going?
Over there.
How to get...
Noise.
Yeah.
Just jump there.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I saw the pie seal.
I don't think I need to get up there.
I don't think there's anything actually.
It was all a ruse.
You are tensile.
Tell me something I don't know.
Though we do need to get in here.
So...
Onwards.
Anything in here?
Doesn't look like it.
Onwards.
Oh, no.
This looks scary.
Cats can't taste sweet.
No, don't say that.
Is the outfit new?
It's cute.
No, I just threw it in the dark.
It's on accident.
And it got...
You know...
Oh!
Okay.
They would do that.
Yeah.
That checks out.
I'm hiding.
I'm trying to find...
A place to go.
I'm lost.
Little...
Little lost minky.
Oh, please.
Someone never get the penis to me.
Time for another side quest?
Really?
In the boat?
Oh, gosh.
I was in the right spot?
Okay.
I thought I was, but...
I didn't like it, so I was denying it.
I thought I was in the right spot.
I was like, ooh, I don't like the idea of this, so...
I'm just gonna say...
No.
How do I get these locks?
Wait.
Just kidding.
Don't answer that.
Oh, my God.
When did I...
Ah!
When did I get this gun?
When did I get the revolver?
Wait.
When did I get...
Just now?
Hi.
Dad.
Really?
Is this the supplies?
I just...
No.
Wait.
Which number is that?
Ah!
Okay.
It was on the table.
I just...
I don't even look.
I just grab.
Wait.
No.
Ew.
This thing's powerful.
Ow!
Well, it's powerful if you can aim.
Really?
Stop, please!
Oh, my gosh.
No.
And don't you want me to just keep running?
What?
I'm scared!
I'm running!
Oh, six shots.
Six shots.
Give me the health, please.
I should use my SMG here, maybe.
It's all you need.
It is!
Biggigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigigig
I'm just running for it.
I'm running for it.
I'm running for it!
Thank you for the awkward, Do-do.
Thank you for the hack.
I don't know.
Where is it going to put me?
Oh, okay.
That checks out.
But this is good.
That means I can be prepared.
I didn't notice that door, so...
Now I know that they're coming.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
This is pretty far back, isn't it?
What happened to saving often?
What happened to your manners?
I was in crisis earlier.
Do you... do you say...
Ah!
Okay, I think what I'm gonna do here...
Is I think I'm just gonna run as much as I can.
Run and shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god!
I just kicked my wallet into the trash can.
Um...
And...
And then I...
Once we get into that big room, I need to know where to go.
So I'm just gonna run, run, run...
Into the big room, if I can make it there.
So I can see where...
To go, because...
Having the helicopter will after me at the same time...
It's craziness.
It's all crazy.
Whew!
Okay.
You know what?
I will save here.
Ouch!
It's a good thing I saved.
It just happened to me when I downloaded Umomoshime.
Oh, this is a dead end.
That's so evil!
Okay.
Now we're in.
Let's figure out...
Where we need to go.
Ouch!
That's just blood.
Please?
Come out.
I hear you.
No, there's...
Oh, I can't...
Okay.
That worked...
Well, better than I expected it to.
Oh my god.
Nevermind.
I lied.
I don't...
I don't know where they come from either.
Ow!
Oh!
That's awkward.
Sorry.
I'm almost out of...
Where are you?
Oh!
I need more health.
Before I...
Oh, wait.
Nice.
I see you.
I see you and I hear you.
Oh,
I think that was me actually.
Making all that noise.
No, little me.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
This is not the right...
Oh, I have to jump on top of these.
I see.
You know what?
I...
Will save.
Okay.
Wait.
I probably got more...
No, I did.
Oh.
We'll...
We'll stick with...
This.
Maybe that's...
Not the right thing to do, but...
Whatever.
Oh.
Parkour.
Oh, we get...
We get actually SMG ammo from these guys, so maybe it's fine too.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, the dam.
I was like, what is that?
I thought it was the...
Running.
We're running, running.
Please don't.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no.
Maybe right here I'm safe.
Oh, he's crushing them for me.
Yeah.
Keep going.
Nope, nope, nope.
The boxes are right here.
Yeah, good job.
Good job, Watashi.
Oh my god.
Where?
You can zoom...
With the Magnum.
Kind of.
But...
You can't zoom and shoot, no?
Or can you?
No, it won't let me here.
I see that downstairs.
I think that's a...
Is this a...
Health.
It is.
Is this like a boss?
Are we about to...
Hit a boss?
And that's why it's giving me all this?
Wow.
That's a lot.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh.
I need even more.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeah, you can't zoom and shoot.
So it's kind of frustrating.
You can shoot immediately after unzooming.
It takes practice, but works well.
Ah.
I think I get it.
Ugh.
Trying to figure out when I want to end this.
I didn't realize it's been three and a half hours already.
But I did...
I did also...
Let's try the...
Let's try the fight.
And then maybe I'll...
I'll cut it.
My migraine is actually gone, luckily.
That was so unfortunate.
You got anything for me?
Jeez.
Can I kill it with the turret?
Take him down!
Oh.
Uh.
Here.
Is he gone?
Okay.
That makes things a little bit more peaceful now, doesn't it?
Holy.
Thank you, mister.
Sure.
The wind noises reminds me of...
When you're going around the...
What's it called?
Oh.
No, no.
I wanted to go up that.
The...
There's a par in MGS3.
You're like climbing up on the mountain and stuff.
That's just windy noises.
Reminds me of.
Good place to stop.
Should we stop today?
Here.
I'm having a lot of fun though.
Oh.
Well.
Come on.
Let me parkour, please.
Why do I suck?
I don't know.
Gordon Freeman.
The man.
Well never...
You're just making it worse.
Next part is really stressful, is it?
Hmm...
Maybe there's nothing up here anyway.
Anyway, I can't tell.
I would be able to tell if I could see...
Oh well, anyway.
Okay, I give up.
I'm too big.
We have to go all...
We don't have to go all the way back, actually.
I lied.
Because there was a hole right over here.
I saw it.
Right here.
But also, I think I can just jump this.
Easy.
High core.
Baby.
I wish I could remember if there was any place that had health that I could...
That I...
Forgot, like, couldn't grab because I was full before.
I'm just gonna go.
If I die, I'll end it.
I'll end it all!
I
was gonna say, that looks like mines.
Meow, meow!
What?
What if you never die?
So true.
Who's shooting at me?
Sick drip.
We made it!
I saved, and it saved as well.
Wow, this is so beautiful!
Wait, am I going the wrong way?
Oops!
I'm going the wrong way?
I'm going to die!
Never punished!
The music is really cool, though.
Wait, the music's so cool.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh.
Can I go through here?
Ouch, ous, ous, ous, ous, ous.
Yeah, I saw those planks, baby.
Oh my god, ous.
Oh, I'm not gonna...
I thought I was gonna hit it for sure.
That was crazy.
That was a sick joke.
Let's go!
Oh my god, it's getting even tighter in here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Okay, okay, we're good.
We're fine.
I saw!
I saw that!
Over there!
Oh, where?
Where to?
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, okay.
Break the door!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Wait, you guys, I'm stuck, actually.
Wait, you guys, I'm stuck.
Oh!
Anyway...
No hidden headcrab?
Evil, evil, evil, evil.
Someone said it's over.
It's definitely not.
Evil!
Okay.
Alright.
Um, I'm not quite...
Oh, can we get on this?
And then go down?
That'd be kind of neat.
Oh, there's supplies up here!
I almost missed it, but I got everything that I needed.
Okay.
Whew.
Huh.
Nyet?
No?
I cannot?
Park on the lift, then use it.
I got past the hardest part?
No way!
I thought I could do like a sick...
Like a damn...
She...
Jumped right into the sea!
I made it!
I don't know.
He's still exploding!
Stop!
Wait, will I make it?
Oh!
I made it!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
They're not gonna make it!
They made it!
Ouch!
That was my favorite part of the dinosaur ride.
At Disney.
So basically, the...
the plot...
Wait, did I make it?
For real?
Ouch.
The plot of the dinosaur ride is...
you are going back in time...
to find an Iguanodon.
Um, because that has nothing to do with the actual dinosaur movie, but the Iguanodon was the main character.
I don't remember his name.
It might have just been Iguanodon.
Who knows?
But... Yeah, Iguanodon.
And... You go back in time to go find one, and they're just like, nope, that's...
That's a... That's a... Triceratops.
Try to find another one.
And then they're just like, oh, by the way, we also sent you back in time 30 seconds!
Or like, it was like one minute, or it was like 30 seconds before the meteor hits.
So they're just like... They're like, oh my god, you have to go right now!
You have to go immediately!
Why didn't they send us back with more time?
Who knows?
Yeah, this is the one at Animal Kingdom.
And then, at the very end of the ride, the guy is like, they're not gonna make it!
They're not gonna make it!
They made it!
It's so funny.
If you ever watch a video of it, the end is just so funny.
Because he's like, they're not gonna make it!
They're not gonna make it!
This is so silly.
Are we still in hell?
Or am I like, safe now?
Am I still in... am I being pursued?
Am I being courted still?
Safe for now.
I don't know if I believe you.
It's a puzzle time.
Well, this needs to be lifted.
Oh, there's also a pier.
Briefly safe.
You can have a little safety as a treat.
Hold on, let's look over here.
See what we got going on around.
Oh, gosh.
Nasty.
Spooky.
I don't need it, though.
Actually, I went from having five health.
Well, I guess that was a while ago, but...
We've really come around, huh?
Okay, I see this ladder here.
Let's see where it goes.
There's a lot going on in here.
Isn't there?
Ah!
Okay.
Everything's coming up.
Mink.
Oh.
I tried to run.
Oh, it's because of my flashlight.
Ugh.
Has anyone made a mint pixel R&W place yet?
What is a W place?
But I did see some people making some.
Yeah.
Coral, welcome back.
Thank you.
No need to run?
Oh, because I'm just getting here?
The washing machine?
Maybe...
Is this thing so heavy?
I fell too.
A map where people draw...
Deltarune characters.
Then why am I there?
Oh.
Lift with your back.
I thought I was supposed to be so strong.
Come on, Gordon Freeman.
You can't even lift up a...
Washing machine?
I mean, they're gonna have a nap.
Have a nice nap!
Half-Life 2 was groundbreaking at the time.
Still quite fun, but definitely shows its...
Age with awkward...
Lurches from combat sections to seesaw puzzles.
I don't mind it so much, actually, though.
I'm having so much fun.
Which I...
I'm having so much fun, but I think I will...
Since we did get through the...
That...
Ah!
I
did it!
But also...
Wait, there was a...
Oh, this...
Guys...
Guys, I thought that this tunnel was facing this direction.
I was like, gosh, there's so much to explore.
I didn't realize this is where I came from.
Why do I have big brain moments like this?
And then...
My brain also...
It's so small...
Do I go, thank you so much for the tech...
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, though, for all your help.
This has been so much fun.
It's definitely...
Um...
Definitely, I can...
I...
Play is much more smoothly.
It's much more forgiving than...
Half-Life 1.
Which tends to be the case with these...
Types of games.
You know, series and stuff like that.
But...
Oh, it's so much fun!
And I saved.
Wait.
I'm just going to save again.
New save.
Save.
Oh, oh, oh.
Not a...
Not a quick save.
A real save.
Yeah!
So...
This was fun!
We will continue next week!
Next week!
Thanks for the streaming key.
Loving the retro game arc recently.
Also, top quality boots and history stream.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for streaming at the time that you did.
Yeah!
I will stream at this time again next week as well.
So...
Yes, yes, yes.
I'll re-watch the VOD because it was fun!
That's...
That's so sweet!
Am I late?
No.
Well, I mean...
You...
You came to...
You came at all.
You came to watch it all.
So I appreciate that.
Yeah, but...
Well, yeah.
Fun stream!
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, big chuggers.
And...
Q97JW0ARF.
Welcome to membership to Akku!
And next time...
What does that mean, K-Barn?
I'm scared.
Thank you!
Thank you.
I had a productive morning at work.
Thanks for listening to you.
Thanks, guys.
Two!
Thanks, try for this!
Thank you, guys.
Stay dangerous.
I'm not streaming tomorrow.
So you got...
If I see you on Sunday...
I'll see you Sunday.
But it will be a...
Collab, so...
So...
Maybe...
Less talking with you guys.
Thanks for the stream!
Is it done because of work?
No worries!
Welcome back, Freeman.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
400K soon!
Fact yourself, thank you for the...
Oh my gosh.
Couple your profile picture.
The lonely Gengar.
I don't know what game yet with Nimi.
I gotta figure something out.
But after we played the Emissary Zero...
All of us together...
Nimi was like...
I really like those...
These like...
Kind of goofy...
Stupid horror games.
I was like...
Me too!
And since we have our...
Our collab...
Cover coming out soon...
I thought that...
We could do something...
Just...
Hormie!
Johnny, thank you for the 5th!
Thank you!
Okay!
Well, you guys have a wonderful rest...
Of your day or night...
Or whatever time it is for you...
And...
Um...
What was I gonna say?
Oh!
Enjoy your Saturday...
If you have Saturday off...
Get some rest...
And...
Chill and relax...
And have a good time...
Taste himself...
Thank you so much for the 5th!
Good to do that girl!
And I will see you guys...
When I see you...
Next!
Once upon a time!
Iã£ã¦ã‚‰ã£ã—ã‚ƒã„!
Thank you guys!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye bye!